Rachel Greene is one of the most
beloved characters on "Friends," but
is she a good friend? After a long casting
period, a then-relatively unknown Jennifer
Aniston landed the role, the last "Friends"
character to be cast. During "Friends:
The Reunion," the series' producers also
admitted that in the wrong hands, Rachel
would have been very "unlikable," and it took so
long to find the perfect person to portray her.
"You know, when I did it, at first
I was scared. But look at me now!
I'm the only daughter that Dad is proud of!"
Though Aniston did make Rachel a character
millions of fans across the world love,
there's a lot about her that isn't so great.
For one, Rachel is a pretty horrible roommate.
She barely cooks, doesn't help clean up,
and refuses to move out of the apartment
even when Monica wants to leave and live with
her boyfriend Chandler. Rachel was a bully in
high school and pretty self-centered as
an adult — and who could forget the time
she lost Ross' pet monkey Marcel because
she didn't want to miss her soap opera?
That's not to mention Rachel's messy love
life. Early on, Rachel leaves her fiancé
Barry at the altar, and she later has an
affair with him while he's married to Mindy,
Rachel's longtime best friend who served as the
maid of honor in her cancelled wedding to Barry.
Later in the series, Rachel flies to England
and inadvertently breaks up Ross' wedding
to Emily. And, in a totally cringey storyline,
she also hooks up with Ross' best friend Joey.
However, these moments pale
in comparison to something
terrible Rachel does to Monica — in a
"Friends" scene that simply goes too far.
Over the course of the series' run, Rachel
does some things to Monica that aren't very
best-friendly. For example, in Season 2, when
the pair visit the set of the movie "Outbreak 2:
The Virus Takes Manhattan," they spot actor
Jean-Claude Van Damme. Monica reveals to
Rachel that she has a huge crush on the
actor but is too nervous to talk to him;
Rachel approaches him, acting as if she'll
put in a good word for Monica, and ends up
securing a date with the movie star herself. In a
flashback scene to the 1980s from a later episode,
Rachel kisses Chandler while knowing Monica was
crushing on him. But the worst was yet to come.
In the Season 7 episode "The One with Monica's
Thunder," Rachel starts feeling lonely because
Monica has found her person in
Chandler and she still hasn't.
On the night of a planned outing to
celebrate the newly engaged couple's news,
Rachel goes to Ross and starts kissing him,
planning a "bonus" one-night stand night with him.
Monica opens her apartment door to see
her brother kissing Rachel in the hall.
She accuses the exes of stealing all of the
attention by reuniting on what was supposed
to be "her" big night. For Monica, this was
the Rachel move that really went too far.
While that scene has gone down in history
as one of Rachel's worst moments, she later
one-ups Monica at her own wedding. Just before
Monica and Chandler's wedding, Phoebe discovers
a discarded positive pregnancy test in the
trashcan of Monica and Chandler's bathroom.
She believes that it's Monica's, but when Monica
clears the air and says she isn't expecting,
Phoebe makes a snap decision and pretends she
is to cover for Rachel. Later on, Rachel takes a
pregnancy test ... during the wedding reception,
when Monica is supposed to be celebrating.
Many "Friends" fans agree that Rachel could have
gone about this differently and not overstepped
on Monica and Chandler's special day. As this
was coming near the end of the series run for
"Friends," it makes sense. Sitcoms generally have
to keep upping the ante as they move forward,
leading to this major shift
for the final few seasons.
Though Monica isn't upset with Rachel
about what happens on her wedding day,
a detail that baffles fans to this day,
the icing on the spotlight-stealing cake
is the fact that when Rachel gives birth
to her daughter, she names her Emma — the
name Monica wanted to name her daughter
one day. Classic Rachel Greene move.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite TV series are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.